ننتقل الان الى كلمه للرئيس الاسرائيليه
اسحاق
هرتو
بزو
اه ومن يداوي هؤلاء الذين تتمزق قلوبهم
هؤلاء الذين يقتلونهم افضل الافضل هم
الاجمل هم لبؤات
واسود اعزائي جميعا
ان ابنائنا وبناتنا الذين يقاتلون الان
ببساله ويضحون بانفسهم في الزقاق وفوهات
الانفاق وبين كثبان الرمال في منطقه العدو
الملئه
بالتحديات ويحققون
انجازات ويقاتلون بشجاعه واسر وخلاق
وبمسؤوليه من اجل تحقيق الهدفين المرتبطين
احدهما
الاخر الانتصار على هذا العدو الوحشي
واعاده مختطفين من
واقرا موقين الى الوطن
والدفاع يحاربون من اجل الدفاع عن وطننا
جميعا بحرب لا بد منها ضد مخربين وحشيين
يحاربون من اجل ان نعود
الى سفك الدماء مره اخرى يحاربون من اجل
ان يكون لنا شعب اسرائيل وضع افضل ومن اجل
ان تكون كل المنطقه
والانسانيه ومستقبل افضل ومن اجل ان اخينا
واخواننا المخطوفين يعودون الى الوطن
بسرعه
الوضع امامنا واخرنا المخطوفون هم محتجزون
بايدي حماس هو وحشي وغير انساني وواجبنا
اعا وايضا موجود في وعينا لن نرتاح ولن
نسكت حتى يعود الى الوطن ولا ننسى اننا في
اوج حرب ضد من جاؤوا لقتل اليهود
واذبحوا واغتصبوا وعذبوا يهودا مسلمين
وايضا ابناء اديان مختلفه ول عليه من
المهم ان اقول لكم الليله ان
حرب لا بد منها وهي حرب صعبه
ومتواصله
وديمه وايضا ليس فها نهايه وايضا في هذا
اليوم
الصعب ممنوع علينا ان ننكسر ويجب علينا ان
نرفع
راس العدو ينتظر ان نرى شروخا بيننا وان
نتحاور او ان وان نتواجه من اجل الانا
والسياسه وايضا اليوم قبل واليوم بعد
وايضا في كل مره ان تكون لدى الانقسام
وايضا من اجل ذلك انا اطلب
ان هنا ان اضع الصدقه لمئات العائلات
الثله
وايضا الجبهه و مؤمنو بيت اسرائيل الذين
التقيتهم في الاونه الاخيره وان ادعو
جميعا دعونا ان نتوقف عن الخلاف في هذه
الحرب
الصعبه الجدالات هو جزء
منا وهو مطلوب وايضا ان الانتقاد هو مطلوب
في ساحه الحرب ولكن هناك طريق كيف ان
نتواجه ممنوع ان نعود الى الحوار في
السادس من
اكتوبر ممنوع ان نحضر الى القول نحن وهم
وايضا ان يكون هناك السموم في المواقع
الاجتماعيه ايضا انا احذر كل من يعيدنا
الى حوار السادس من اكتوبر الذي يضر
بالجهود الحربيه وبام مواطني اسرائيل وانا
اتوجه بشكل مباشر الى قيادتنا والى كل من
يعمل في المجال السياسي والجماهيري واطلب
التوقف وان يظهروا المسؤوليه اذا لكم من
اجلكم
من اجل اولادنا وجنودنا في الجبهه ومن اجل
امنهم
وسلامتهم انتظروا قليلا مع هذه الرموز
السياسيه وايضا ان يكون هناك لدى الجمهور
الوحده والتصميم وايضا
الكفاله المشتركه نحن في حرب لا بد منها
ولا مفر منها صادقه واخلاقيه هذه الطريق
نكتفي بهذا القدر في هذه الكلمه للرئيس
الاسرائيلي اسحاق هيرتزوج